shot clock at five and he is  fouled as he was taking it inside a  congested lane  i wonder if doc will challenge this  right here  [Applause]  the foul goes on beverly who's over  there pleading his case  he's telling him a challenge  [Laughter]  and beverly comes up with his fourth  kind of hard to tell from that angle  right there  [Applause]  now they go to grant beverly is there  look at the defense by beverly look at  the move by grant  who offers a shoulder in the pants chops  and down goes beverly and  that's another foul look at he is so  feisty  but that's how that's how he has made  this league that's why he's lasted as  long as he's lasted and played and  such valuable technical foul too yep  on beverly we're not the time to get it  uh oh he's just been tossed  wow  so murray will be at the line the  clippers beverly is  obviously frustrated  and he is gone so they'll bring in  shamit to take his place